I think the last thing I mentioned to
you was the attempted coup data on the
part of a nobleman by the name of
Kahlon who was attempting to establish a
tyranny of the sort that were becoming.
That was becoming common in
the neighborhood and that
he was the son in law of a
tyrant.
Next door mega it the coup failed.
But the problems that we imagine
produced the coup did not go away.
And one sees evidence of continuing
pressure for change away from the
traditional aristocratic Republic which
the early polls was towards something
that would challenge the unquestioned
traditional rule of the aristocracy in.
Again these are all traditional dates
and shouldn't be taken too seriously as
precise but probably reflect a pretty
decent chronology in a general way so that
in the traditional year of six twenty one
we hear that Athens received its first
written law code famous as the code of
Draco or in Greek it would be Dirac Kahn
and the reports that we have of it
indicate that one kind of law that was
included in the code was concerning
homicide which has a special place in the
Greek thinking probably it's true of
most primitive societies that homicide
involves religious ideas.
The Greeks believed that killing of men
was accepted more time was a religious
pollution that had to be taken
care of one way or another.
Beyond that there was also the primitive
thing that was not particularly
religious but reflected primitive thinking
of all homicides need to be avenged.
And so the blood feud was clearly part
of the way to deal with homicide and
early Greek history.
And as is true of most early societies
there comes a time when that no longer
will do that there is a
sufficient civilization
urbanization whatever it is that
made the change that people
feel this has got to stop.
One reason it does is of course
it tears a community apart.
And as you are in the business of building
a community which is what's happening
here in the polls you
can't have that going on.
One reason it is the way to settle
things is because there isn't any proper
government.
There are only these noblemen.
There is a council to be sure but it's
all a question of going to somebody who
has power and has respect and
getting a judgment from them.
But as time passes that's not good enough.
And as the community becomes something
that is more I'm more unified.
There is a search for a better outcome.
And that is what resulted in the code of
Draco which just the fact that there is
a written code so that it is now available
to anybody who can read which is not
to say lots of people but even so people
who can read can now tell it to other
people.
That very fact is the sign of the
decline of the power of the aristocracy
because they alone used to know what
the law was or a claim to know it and
people would go to them
and say what's the law.
And they could administer it as they saw
fit which gave them extraordinary power
not to say prestige.
Now when it is possible at least in some
realms of the law to know what that law
is that has reduced the special place
that the Aristocrats have in society
stories are told about the code of Draco
Like most early law codes and we can't
compare the draconian code with famous
or less famous ones much older that we
find especially in Mesopotamia
and the Ancient Near East.
The most famous of these because it has
been inscribed on a remarkable piece of
sculpture which is now in the Louvre
in Paris the Code of Hammurabi from the
second millennium B.C. is really
quite similar in its essence.
It says if so and so does such a thing.
This is what the punishment is.
And from our point of view
early codes like Draco are
notorious for how harsh they are.
The Greeks later on said that the code
of Draco was written not in ink but in
blood.
And but in fact what it does is to codify
what had been the ordinary practice.
Nobody was inventing laws.
They were writing down what had
been the customary procedures.
And again a characteristic of such
developments is that over time when people
know how harsh these things are.
And as society sort of calms down from
the more wild condition that it was in an
earlier time it tends to
reduce the severity of the
penalties and to legislate.
However the legislation goes
forward in a more gentle way.
So that's another development which is
obviously the consequence of aristocrats
don't give up their power willingly
out of the goodness of their hearts.
This pressure out there.
Scuse me for access to the legal process
for the ordinary person and again I
think it's easy to believe that a lot
of that pressure is coming from that hop
like farmer class that is becoming more
important and more demanding all the
time another change in the old placid
life of the early Athenian Republic as we
imagined it to be is the conquest by
the Athenians of the island of Solomons
that lies in this ironic Gulf to the
west of Attica between Attica and Negara
Athens and mega row will contest the
control of Solomon's for some time and
fight each other over it.
And on this occasion sometime here in
the seventh century probably towards the
end of the Seventh Century Athens
conquers Solomon's and populated with the
Athenians.
It's it's it's it's not really a a colony
in the sense that these outpost Kii I
described for you are.
It simply becomes part of Attica as
do all the subdivisions in Attica.
But it's the first occasion that we
see of the physical expansion of the
Athenian polis which is indicative of the
kind of stuff we've been talking about
elsewhere as well.
And yet another sign takes place about
the same time end of the 7th very early
in the 6th century the establishment
of the first overseas colony by the
Athenians at a place called the CGM
across the GNC just at the entrance to the
Dardanelles to the hellish pond.
And that is not an accident
I think because that route
through the hellish spot
through the Sea of Marmara through the
Bosphorus and into the Black Sea will as
Athens develops economically become the
most critical trade route for Athens
indeed.
After a while when Athens has developed
a mixed economy and become and its
population grows it becomes dependent
on that route for supplying it with the
grain that it needs as the
staple of life for its people.
So this is a first little step towards
a very important development for Athens
in the future.
And I guess the reasons for it late.
And less pressing than in the other
places. But they must be the same.
To some considerable degree hunger for
land which means that there is a growing
population that needs additional land
and also because of the location of it.
It's inescapable I think that they are
also thinking that early of commercial
considerations.
And it turns out that there were very
great commercial opportunities in that
direction.
So we've seen a number of signs of change
moving Athens in the direction that
the other Greek states were moving.
Which brings us in the early
6th century to the first.
I think it's I think I've said this
before but I want to say it again to the
first truly living human being that we
come across probably in all of Greek
history certainly in that of Athens.
So on whom we think of as the great
law giver for reasons that you've read
about. And I'll tell you
about in a moment anyway.
The reason he is so much we can speak
of him as a human being because he wrote
those poems from which I read you
some expert excerpts the other day.
And that poem tells us something about
him and about the world in which he lived
and will and of course we have many many
stories about him because he was very
well remembered as a critical individual
in the history not only of Athens but
in Greece.
The Greeks later put together a list of
the Seven Sages seven wise men of the
archaic period in Greek history and
so long is one of the Seven Sages.
Indeed one of the problems about knowing
the truth about what solong did is that
it's pretty clear that lots of stories
that had nothing to do with so long were
attached to so on in later ages because
he was the prominent figure that
everybody had heard about
and knew something about.
And so it isn't easy to know if somebody
says so long did this or so long said
that whether he really did.
We can only try to sort of
figure it out as best we can.
But that's a special
problem we have about him.
Now what comes
becomes apparent as soon as we examine
the things that brought so long to the
fore is that Athens is clearly suffering
a very serious internal problem as we
get to these years by the
way the traditional date
for so long's appointment as
sole Arkan in these years
is five ninety four B.C..
Again we don't have to take that literally
but it tells you we're really talking
about the very beginning
of the sixth century.
Here's the picture as it is depicted by
so long himself in his poems but also in
the work of Herodotus
and other later writers
the crisis in its most acute form takes
the shape of Athenians who have been
enslaved.
Some of them have not only been enslaved
and live in Attica as slaves but some
of them have been sold abroad and stolen
tells us that some of them have been
abroad so long they have forgotten the
Athenian language so that we have to have
a picture in which this this
problem is one of some duration.
We have to imagine it's at least
a couple of generations old.
In order for that to make any sense.
But it reaches its peak around the time
I'm talking about and it's this that how
did they get to be slaves.
This is not a case where
people had always been slaves.
These are not people who were brought
from somewhere else as slaves.
These are not people who were conquered
and made slaves by the conquerors.
These are Athenian citizens who used to
be free and have become slaves and the
answer to how they became
slaves is through debt.
People were borrowing money and
obviously failing to pay it back.
And at a certain point they
couldn't borrow money on
the basis of something they
could offer as a surety for the loan.
If they had land that would have been
gone by now if they had movable products
or movable possessions that would have
been gone all they had left to give was
the person and probably I hate to tell
you this my friends but the reality is
reality.
Probably the first thing they did was to
give their children as a surety for the
loan and when the loan was not met the
children became slaves of the person who
had lent them money and very at some
point probably this even happened to grown
ups themselves so that a sufficient number
of people had been so enslaved as to
create a very general problem.
The story is that apart from direct
slavery there was another form of
farming by very poor people
that was led to terrific misery.
The term that the Greeks used for this
was the heck tame or Roy which means one
sixth men and scholars have argued
about what does this mean that the.
These were people who who had been so
far into debt that they were essentially
sharecroppers. And the question
is did they keep one sixth of it.
Did they keep five sixth.
I think anybody who knows anything about
what's possible on a farm like this
realizes it couldn't have been more than
one sixth that they gave away because
they didn't make enough.
They wouldn't been able to stay alive
but in any case these one sixth men were
fundamentally sharecroppers under the
control of the people to whom they owe the
debt.
And another aspect of this thing was
that the lands that were mortgaged in
effect were the mortgage was shown by a
stone that had the mortgage inscribed on
it and placed on the soil.
They were called poor Roy and so the
seeing the hall rise spares scattered all
over the fields were indicative of the
pitiful lot of the poor farmers who had
fallen into debt
during this period.
Well scholars also had a fantastic time
trying to figure out how this came about
and I never found anything that seemed
satisfactory to me based on looking at
the sources or reading people's
interpretations until once again.
My hero Victor Hanson came on down
the road and he's a man of honor.
It's just amazing how much that helps
him understand farmers and I like his
interpretation of how things got that way.
So let me give you a quick
rundown of how that work.
Remember these these times are the
times and fundamentally of a growth of
farming skill growth farming return people
making living on areas farm farmland
that they could never have made a living
on before because they've learned how
to grow the olive and grow the vine and
make olive oil and make wine and have
reclaimed land from which had not
been useful for farming in the past.
And that's how they got into trouble
because for one thing farmers don't all
succeed in any society.
There are farmers who try to be good
farmers and fail and they fail sometimes
through their own shortcomings and they
fail sometimes because nature is not
kind to them. Luck is always
part of the game in farming.
But what happens is that they get into
trouble because things don't go well.
They start out they have a crop
and the crop doesn't do well.
So they need money for next year both to
make it through the winter and also to
have seed for the following year. So what
they do is have to borrow that money.
And if the next crop is bad too.
Well there you go.
And you can see the
whole process unraveling.
I think that's probably
the way it came about.
According to Hansen the majority of
the farmers were not so affected.
They were doing OK.
It was the losers who were the ones
who were suffering these things.
But there were enough losers so that
this was a very serious problem.
Now this rejects other earlier theories
that for instance that the soil of
Attica had become exhausted
through over cropping and so on.
If Hansen is right this is less likely
to be true than it used to be because
there's more diversity.
Diversification of farming than
there had been in the past.
And another another theory is that a
cause of the problem was deforestation.
Well it's perfectly true that Athens
was severely deforested in the course of
the centuries so that plateau could
comment on how this deforestation had
denuded Athens of trees
by the fourth century.
But there's no reason to think that
that was happening especially during the
time of so long very probably
that deforestation hadn't
gone that far and in any
case its connection to problems of the
farmland are less clear than they might
be. Here's what Hansen
finally concludes about it.
He says the crisis was a
natural evolutionary process
of success and failure a
subtle transformation that occurs when
there are fundamental changes in land use
and a growing population and that
seems to me to be the most satisfactory
account of how the
Athenians got into that fix.
But in that fix they were
there's no question about it.
So the question was what is to be done.
Now the pressure to do something
about it I think is twofold.
Of course inherently Athenians would
have been bothered by all of this.
Even those who were not the
ones who did the suffering.
But it's amazing how we all are able to
bear the suffering of our neighbor if we
are not suffering too.
However the second element I think that
put pressure on everybody was next door
and Negara when things
had gone bad for the poor.
There was a revolution and
the tyranny was established.
And so it was down the road in Corinth.
And so it was a little further down
the road and so on so that the dominant
people the satisfied people the people
who like things as they were were worried
that if they didn't solve their socio
economic problem they would find
themselves confronting a tyranny because
after all that's what Keelan had in
mind back 30 thirty five years ago.
And the danger was ever present.
And I think that is what you
need to have in your mind.
The threat of tyranny was the great
element that made chances or attempts at
reform necessary and allowed the Athenians
to give things a try that they would
never have thought of before.
And so what they finally decided to do
was to select from among themselves.
One Athenian who would replace all the
nine icons of the usual government of
Athens and be given the job of soul
are Kahn for one year and he would be
allowed to legislate for the Athenians
as a way out of the trouble they were in.
Now think of how how
desperate things must be.
And one aspect of that desperation I
think we have to believe is that there was
no way they could have put together a
coalition of citizens who would have been
sufficiently unified sufficiently public
spirited to trust with such an activity
that anybody that we have to believe
that there were sufficient differences of
interest on the part of different elements
in the society that would have made
that impossible.
Otherwise you don't do this kind of thing.
It is worth pointing out that something
like So London's soul our ship is heard
of about the same time in Greek history.
In other towns sometimes they appointed
somebody they called an ICM they chase
somebody who is supposed to be the
guy who settle things for them.
So it's an idea that came obviously
naturally to the Greeks but we ought to
recognize what an extraordinary thing
it really is. They chose so long.
Why did they choose so long.
He obviously was reputed to have the
kinds of characteristics which would make
him a competent intelligent wise
fair person to do this kind of thing.
He had achieved fame notoriety
by his military activity.
He had led in the war against
McGarry ends and had fought very well.
And it was out of that
military achievement that he
became well known and then
his other characteristics
obviously were also well-known.
If you read his poems you realize he was
a man who knew how to express himself
and to persuade others of what he had in
mind and that his approach was one that
was popular. We should keep
in mind what's going on here.
First of all we are told he was a man.
We have contradictory stories.
And I think I can understand
how the contradiction arose.
One story says he was a nobleman
coming from extremely famous important
ancestors.
The other speaks of him as a man of the
middle rank which doesn't really work
out. With that I think best explanation
I can come up with that is that he
undoubtedly was a person of noble birth.
In that kind of society only such a
person was likely to be looked to for a
position of leadership.
But I think what may have persuaded folks.
Well he also couldn't have been fabulously
wealthy but certainly he was not a
poor man.
But what I think convince people that
he was of the middle rank was that his
message and the propaganda that he
sent out in his poems and indeed the
character of the reforms that he
proposed were very much moderate.
That's the word that came to be the one
so much admired and favored and sought
by the Greek people.
Keep in mind this is the period in Greek
history when the Delphic Oracle has
come to the height of its influence in
the Greek world and in the surrounding
world as well.
And the oracle of Apollo at Delphi was
the most famous place that was putting
forward the idea of moderation.
The Greek word is soft Rawson
a self-control and moderation.
And you remember the messages
at the Delphic oracle.
Know thyself meaning don't imagine that
you are more than a man but that you are
merely a man and don't
do anything in excess.
Moderation was what should be sought
weeks never stopped worshiping at the
shrine of moderation for
the rest of their history.
Cynical men say the Greeks were so in
love with moderation because it was so
rare among them.
But I think it's rare among all of us.
So here was someone who was the spokesman
of that very powerful mode of thinking
that was pervading the Greek world at
the time and no doubt he gave it a great
step forward with the things that
he did and the things that he said.
Okay let's look at a few
of the things that he did.
I'm picking out things that I pretty
sure really were so lonely and there were
others that attributed to him that are
more debatable but the most basic problem
is what are we going to do with these
people who are losing their property have
lost their property
have lost their freedom.
What's to be done about that agricultural
problem we've been talking about.
And so.
So Len introduced the measure which
is called in Greek the cease fire.
Fortunately you have it on your computers
and you've all copied it down and
taken it to class so you can study
these things right. Don't answer
that.
That measure abolished all debts that
were based on the body of the person that
is that that were the surety given
was the body of the borrower.
Any debt that was so incurred
was abolished cancelled
on the other hand there was no
general cancellation of debts.
In other words any normal debt that
didn't have that characteristic continued.
Another thing that the poor and
the unhappy would have liked.
They would have like General
cancellation of debt I should point out.
Whenever you have lower class discontent
in the Greek world there are two things
that they typically ask for.
One is abolition of debt
because they're always in debt.
And the second thing is redistribution
of the land now redistribution of the
land means civil war.
Nobody is going to allow his land to
be taken away from him and given to
somebody else without a fight.
And so if you go for that what you're
going to have to do is to have armed force
to achieve it and you're going to end up
with a tyranny because that's the kind
of thing tyrants are more likely to do.
So he avoided that and he did not
permit redistribution of the land.
If you just look at that land question
for a moment and the debt bondage
question you can see that it is indeed
the moderate position in between the view
of those the poor the enslaved indebted
who wanted these radical changes and the
old aristocracy who would have preferred
to just leave things as they were
instead so long came through with this
middling program which and by the way
apparently there was we don't know how
well this was done but apparently they
brought back Athenians who
had been enslaved abroad also.
So there must have been some expenditure
of funds somehow they must have
collected it from somebody
and brought them back.
But the most important thing is
what's done right there in Attica.
And of course to what all of this does
is to settle down the situation for the
moment but it does not guarantee that
these very same problems that produced the
difficulty we're talking about would not
reappear in the future and I think as
we look at this measure it's already
a clue to most everything that's
characteristic of the slowness in reforms.
They are moderate and
therefore unsatisfactory.
That is they don't solve
the problems that are there.
But that doesn't mean they
are not worth anything.
For one thing they ameliorate the problem.
And therefore the ameliorate
the discontent and the
danger to the freedom of the
Athenians.
But they also sometimes set the stage
for the elimination of the problem over
time because ways are found obviously
for people to manage these things if the
possibility of debt slavery is taken
away in other forms of managing these
things will assert themselves.
And indeed what we find.
And I must say what I'm going to
tell you doesn't solve the mystery.
But what we find as you get to the fifth
century the classical period in Athens
is an extraordinary situation
because it's so good and so unusual.
And that is that most Athenian
farmers in the fifth century
seemed to have small but adequate
family farms that allow many many many
Athenians to live in a very satisfactory
way given the expectations that they
had
it never abolished great big land holding
arrangements that some people had.
There always were throughout Athenian
history no matter how thoroughly
Democratic state became.
There always were great differences of
wealth between very wealthy people and
very poor people.
But what is extraordinary and what
would have been very satisfactory to the
Greek political thinkers even
the Aristotle for instance
in the fourth century
is that there was a great middle ground
in which the people were pretty much
like each other in their economic
condition which produces the greatest
stability the greatest satisfaction the
greatest capacity for self-government.
So that was one of the consequences
although it didn't happen as any direct
action by Solana
We are also told by Aristotle
and other ancient sources that
so changed the coin standard for Athens
from one that was used in the West in
the Peloponnese US and in the West to
one that was used in the east and they
changed the way from the the.
I don't even measures if I don't even
coin standard to the you Bolek standard
which as people try to understand why and
how that would work it would have made
trade with the Aegean and the east better.
And of course we know that that's the
area that the Athenians are exploiting
vigorously now although we must recognize
it when the Athenians get rolling in
the trade business they do
tremendously well in the West as well.
But there's a bigger problem with the
story about these coins than any other.
As you know if what I told you before
the almost universal opinion of coin
experts is how could he change the coin
standards. There weren't any coins yet.
Now you're really going to believe them
are you going to believe Aristotle.
You know where I am.
Okay.
In other steps that turned out to
be very important in the long run.
He encouraged the use of the not of
the use of the land for the purpose of
producing cash crops like olive oil and
wine and the Athenians do use more and
more of their soil largely because there's
more and more of their soil that can
grow that and nothing else but as
they do the consequence is to make the
agricultural output of Athens much more
diversified than it had been which saves
you know more diverse your crops the less
chance you have to be wiped out in any
one year by bad results and it is matter
of fact over time it became a very
satisfactory device and helps explain
again the health of Athenian agriculture
when we see it in the
fifth century and later
another thing that he did
you know I should I'm gonna
talk about citizenship for
a moment.
The Greek police were very
jealous of their citizenship.
Their theory of the polls was that all
citizens were the descendants of the
original founders of the city.
In other words everybody in Athens
was a relative of some kind.
Of course it wasn't true.
Certainly in Athens we know there
were many immigrants and so on.
But the fact remains that that was the
normal thinking about it and the notion
of the power the sent tragedy of the
concept of Polis to them is something we
need to understand and that they were
jealous of it and selfish with it.
This was not something they would simply
allow people to acquire if they wanted
it this place is us and it's not them.
And we don't make people citizens.
And that was essentially the thing to
be a citizen of Athens in those days you
had to have a father who
was a citizen of Athens.
Nothing else would do the trick.
But someone changed that.
So long offered citizenship to individuals
who came to Athens to settle and had
a say could could show that they had a
valuable skill a valuable craft and the
results were that Athens would become
in the decades following so long a great
center for the manufacturing
of a variety of things.
Pottery is what we have and great painting
painted pottery is a great part of
the Athenian tradition.
But sculpture also and all kinds of
things that we probably don't have because
they would have been destroyed by time.
But the idea was if you were a skilled
craftsman you could become you come to
Athens and you would not have to
be what you would otherwise be.
Anybody who came to Athens not under
these rules would could stay could make up
himself a permanent resident but he would
always be what the Greeks called a Met
oil costs.
We say in English a metric meaning a
resident alien never to be a citizen.
Only citizens were permitted to own land
in Attica only citizens had access to
the Athenian courts a noncitizen who
had to go to court for one reason or
another would have to find a
citizen to be his spokesman.
So you really were cut off from somewhere
and of course a noncitizen could not
participate in the political life of
Athens either but these people were not
going to be medics because of the
economic skills that they brought so long
arranged for them to
become Athenian citizens.
Very rare thing.
We will have a couple of other occasions
in this course until then take a look
at a moment when foreigners were permitted
to come to Athens and become citizens.
But they're very rare.
And there's always something
very special connected with them.
And there will always be some Athenians
who will raise at least one eyebrow at
the idea of making a
foreigner a citizen of Athens.
But it turned out to be one
of those things that have
that so on instituted that
would have long range consequences
helpful to the Athenian state well so much
for the economic and social issues.
Let's turn to the constitutional
questions because of course by when you're
talking about an independent republic
then the political and constitutional
arrangements are obviously
critical to everybody.
I guess it's true in any society
but it's blatant in a republic.
So someone changed the
Athenian constitution up
to this moment the Athenian
constitution came to be what it was
in the way that these things happen in
nature namely through tradition.
They just kind of grow.
Nobody nobody legislates but so
on was appointed to legislate.
And he was going to attempt to
deal with the problems that he saw.
So what he did first of all was to arrange
Athenian political society on a new
basis.
This is a very large matter up to now
where you were in the state whether you
could serve on the council whether you
could be a magistrate dependent upon your
birth aristocrats alone
could hold these positions.
Now that was swept away by Solana's
new system he changed it so that the
determination of who was eligible to
serve in these councils and offices was
based on the wealth that
they had just to show you.
And this is an argument against the
coinage being present in that day.
He did not fix the rating of
Citizens for these jobs in money.
He rated them in measures of agricultural
produce whether dry produce or liquid
produce equally available.
These measures of produce were
called medium Noi measures.
So here's how we worked it out at the
top of the scale. There were five.
You had to have each year
products produced by your
land which were worth five
hundred Madame Noi at least.
So the people who held in that position
that condition were described as get
ready.
This is a job breaker Pentecost CEO
Madame Noi which just means five hundred
measurement.
That is obviously a new term a new
concept didn't exist before so it makes no
sense.
So someone had to invent that to take
care of a certain class of people that he
wanted.
But the next class down was probably
almost certainly used for a condition that
was already recognized but didn't have
a formal place in the Constitution.
People with three hundred measures a
year but not five hundred were called hip
pace meaning cavalryman.
I use that term in another place
before and then people with two hundred
measures but not three hundred were zoo
Gotye yoke fellow as you remember yoke
men and then those below two hundred
were feats and they were the lowest class
in the Athenian Society
invented by someone again
that was an old term the only
one that he invented was
the Pentecost yo Madam NOI
and of course the critical thing about
it more whatever else I say about this
the important thing it broke the
monopoly of aristocrats by birth in the
political realm the first two classes
Pentecostal home Adam NOI and hip pace
could hold the Archon ships and only they.
Now the Zuber tie as I think I mentioned
to you before were essentially the hop
like class that meant they could not hold
the top jobs in the state on the other
hand he established a council of four
hundred the word for council in Greek is
bu Lei so this bu lay of 400 Xu Gotye
could serve on that and we we never will
really know what the powers
of that council were because
it doesn't seem but as
we shall see so once Constitution was
never really put into effect in all its
respects although this business about
the measures was put into effect
but I think we can guess by analogy to
other councils that it would have had
considerable power that it would have
decided many things would not have been an
empty honor to be on the Council of 400
nor were the seats excluded from political
power entirely they of course made up
a part of the assembly the Greek word
is a clay C up and that there was
certainly a net Clay C before so long you
always in any state that we know of in
the Greek world if you want to go to war
you must go to the army now the seats
didn't fight as hot lights but they
could fight as light on the troops so I'm
sure they were consulted although it
was pretty much a formality nonetheless
that's not no but what is
new and extremely important
is that so on invents a
new kind of court
it is cold in.
The heli Aya
and what it is is a court of appeal
all this time before every magistrate
as I believe I mentioned had a court of
his own that dealt with matters
that were appropriate to his court.
And that was the end of it.
I suppose theoretically and probably
in reality sometimes if somebody didn't
like what a magistrate decided in the
court he could go to the area of us and in
very rare occasions I would imagine Gary
octopus could do something about it.
But I think what we have to assume is
that a decision by the magistrate's court
was it and the game was over heli Aya.
On the other hand was a court of appeals.
That's critical.
Anybody who didn't like the decision
that he got in a magistrates court could
take it to a heli IO and then
have that decision overturned.
If the court so decided and that court
was a truly popular court it was open to
all adult male Athenian
citizens even the seats.
That is something very
new really quite radical.
The most radical elements surely in this
very moderate program that that so long
puts forward notice.
He still gives the aristocracy privileges
that nobody else has in the right to
hold the I say aristocracy but I mean
the richest people in the state in that
they alone can hold the arcane ship which
would have been troubling to the poor.
But then he gives this new founded
court of appeals to the poorest Athenian
citizens which would certainly
have rankled the rich.
And that's characteristic of
what he is up to this court.
Here's the way it.
Every year Athenians could volunteer
to be enrolled in the panel that would
produce the courts of the heli.
And the number of Athenians on
on this panel was six thousand.
And then on any occasion when there
had to be an actual court case then the
members people on the on the enrolled
list there would be some way of picking
the numbers you needed for the jury.
We know how it worked in the classical
period but we can't be sure it work the
same way.
And so lunch time.
But in the classical period it's a very
complicated way of choosing jurors which
was a.
But such a wonderfully complicated
allotment device that it guaranteed that
nobody would know who was going to sit
on a particular jury until they walked
into the room and began to hear the case
and that was to avoid corruption of a
jury.
So whether that system was in play or
not I don't think it was in the detail.
And so on time the idea should be clear.
These things are really going to be
unfixable and ordinary Athenians are going
to be the ones who are
making the decisions later
theoreticians of politics of
democracy would fix on that as the single
most important step towards democracy
that the Athenians would ultimately reach.
But by no means would Solon's constitution
if it had been put into effect have
amounted to a thoroughgoing democracy.
And yet the tradition always was
there that so long had done something
democratic because as you go into the
fourth century people looking back without
any real good knowledge of what
went on back in those days.
Some of them listed so long
as the founder of Democracy.
But it's also true that the general on
understanding was not wrong about this
because there was the same tradition at
the same time that it wasn't the same
kind of democracy we have
now in the fifth century.
It is it was less democratic and that
I think those traditions were correct.
But
moderation again is the example
of what I'm talking about.
Well brilliant marvelous someone was so
clever he realized that when you're a
moderate the wonderful achievement of
a moderate person is that everybody is
dissatisfied
because the guys on that end are unhappy
in the guise of our own that they're
unhappy.
And so he knew that they would immediately
be efforts to overthrow what he had
done.
And so he one of his stipulations was
that the Athenians would have to leave his
laws unchanged for ten years.
And he also knew that his own life
would be extremely uncomfortable hanging
around Athens while everybody came and
said What the hell did you do so long.
And so he left town and we're trapped
went on his travels for ten years after
that.
Well it saved him a lot of grief
but it didn't save his legislation.
Because there was tremendous strife in
Athens after the year of Solon's ship.
Indeed something resembling chaos.
I think they were
technically years of anarchy.
That is to say there was so much dispute
and conflict in Athens that they were
unable to elect the nine hour cons just
years with no outcomes no name for the
year.
That was how serious the conflict was
and what emerges in our records about
what was happening is that localism
regionalism was very powerful in Attica
and it was regionalism that was a large
part of the problem in this period.
Important figures in the aristocracy from
different parts of Attica each sought
to make itself the dominant
force in Athenian society
and to bring about changes
that were satisfactory to them but
they ran into the fact that they had
competition to make it more complicated
wasn't even a nice one against one thing.
There were three factions that were
identified by the Greeks and by the
Athenians and they all
struggle one against the other.
Let's start with the regional
character of these places
one such region was called
the people in their faction.
Let me back up.
The region was called Peralta and the
people who were in the factional called
parolee ie pro rally oi modern scholars
identify the parolee with the southern
tip of Attica starting some distance
up from Sunni him on the West Coast and
carrying a little bit
around to the east coast.
And that was a region that was dominated
by that family I've mentioned to you
earlier that then family that was held
responsible for the killing of the
supporters of Kyla.
That family was the alchemy on day and
their leading figure at the moment we're
talking about was a man called Mega
Cleaves who was one of the competitors for
the leading position in Attica.
According to the ancient writers of the
fourth century very hard to know how
much they really knew about it
it's a matter of speculation.
But anyway what they say is these
people wanted a middling moderate
constitution.
They were probably very close to trying
to retain the slowness in legislation.
Another faction were called the PDR coy
and they represented the middling part
of Attica which is in fact the very best
land in Attica where the grain and wheat
especially were global and the richest
people had their land.
Their leader was a man named like
Fergus and they represented the old
aristocracy more than any other group
and would have undoubtedly if they'd had
their way just undone the colonial
laws and gone back to the old days
they favored some kind of oligarchic
regime and then the third group lived in
the region called D Korea and
they were called the cream boy.
Sometimes some of our sources
say who parent Ackroyd.
I'll come back to that in just a moment.
Well Miles we'll talk about it now.
It is identified with the region on
the east coast of Attica and which was
called the Democracy.
But it's why they might have been called
Hooper our Chris why is that there were
some mountains between central Attica
and the Acharya which meant so that.
I mean beyond the mountains.
And that would have been a
geographical description of the region.
It's the leader of this faction
was a man called Pi sister Tess
who was as matter of fact he
was a nobleman an aristocrat.
All of them were but he his family had
come from the Peloponnese as back in the
years of the Great Migration following
the fall of the Meissen the world.
And that shows you that the Athenians had
brought into their bosoms at that time
and made full citizens and aristocrats
and leading people some people from
outside of Attica.
Now it was hundreds of years later and
persisted as a rose as the leader of that
place and of those people.
Now he's gonna be very important we
need to say a few more words about him.
In the quarrel about what shall be done
what should be done by Sister this and
his group with the most radical.
They represented the views of the
poorest people in Attica and pressed for
solutions of the kinds
that they would like
himself had risen to
power in the usual way.
He had been a great soldier and had won
great victories for the Athenians and
was deeply honored. For that reason
and we'll hear more from him.
Ancient writers speak of him as de Motta
Coke to toast the most demotic the most
popular the most democratic if you will.
So here are the three factions with
their local places with their different
policies presumably in their different
leaders all struggling for power and
sufficiently equal in strength so
that nobody could come out on top.
Out of this.
And by the way when on comes home and the
situation is as unsatisfactory as I've
described so long as becomes particularly
worried about my sister this whom he
has spotted as a potential tyrant and
he goes out and he warns the people
against my sister this but the fact of
the matter is he fails and his warnings
and his predictions turn
out to be accurate as pie
sister this does bring about
tyranny in Athens for the stretch of time
that he and his sons will dominate the
place
he was engaged in that war against Negara
and was the number one hero in that
war.
He was wounded and when he came back
he said that he was in danger from his
enemies who were going to try to kill him.
And he asked the people to
supply him with a bodyguard.
They did so and he pretty quickly took
the opportunity to use his bodyguard to
seize the Acropolis and to make himself
the boss of Athens for a five year
stretch from about five
sixty one to five fifty six.
He was able to rule Athens.
We know very little about
the details of that period.
But he was a proper
tyrant one way or another.
Then his the two factions
that were defeated managed
to get their heads together
to plot and to overthrow the tyranny
to drive by system it is out.
So he goes for a period
of time he goes abroad.
He wanders around meets with other
important people goes to see other tyrants
becomes friendly with other tyrants
finds one way or another to make a lot of
money and to get very rich.
This is important because he is able
to use this money for hiring mercenary
soldiers which will play a large part
in his restoration but not the first
restoration that comes about because
of the two factions that had gotten
together to drive him out had by now
come to quarrel with one another and so
taking advantage of their dissent.
He made a deal with one
of the faction leaders.
It was our old friend Meghan Cleese the
alchemy in it and now united with mega
Achilles.
The two of them drove out their opponents
in the form of like Kirkus and his
people and persistence this
was restored to the tyranny.
Why did Maggie please get out of it.
Well he got guarantees that he would be
a big shot and one part of the guarantee
was that by Sister those who had
had a wife and children already.
I assume she died the first wife now
married the daughter of Megan please in
time immemorial. That's the way
to produce political associations.
Marry the one and one guy
marries the other one's daughter.
So there we are now the story of how my
sister is coming back to power in this
second time is charming and I think
we have to believe it in its general
outlines. Well you can decide
whether you want to or not.
The story is told in
a couple of places but
Aristotle and his Athenian
Constitution tells it in one way
my sister's got a tall beautiful girl.
And he dressed her up to look like Athena
and he put her on a chariot and had
her drive through the attic countryside
and people his boys running alongside
her shouted Athena is bringing
back pies sister us to Athens.
Well you're not going to cross
your patron Didi are you.
And so they all sort of you can imagine
them just sort of kowtowing and saying
Heil My sister is the favorite of Athena
Well the fact that he had a lot of
soldiers and that he had the mega clays
on his side undoubtedly played a large
part in the success.
But there he is back and
everything would have been all right
I guess except that after a while BAE
Systems let me back up a step by system.
This is wife the daughter of Megan
please began going home to her father and
mother and telling him the sad stories.
She said her husband was not
performing his husband's lead duties.
Why was this.
Was she particularly offensive.
No there's no such record as that it's
clear enough that what was worrying
persist to this was that he did not
want to mess up the clarity of the
succession of his sons to the tyranny.
If he had children with Megan please and
they grew up maybe they would contest
the succession.
And so it was for his I guess you'd have
to say it was in his role as a loyal
and devoted father that he got
himself into all kinds of trouble.
Well Meghan please felt a the insult be
the fact that his grandchildren would
not be in charge.
And finally I have to believe even in a
Greek father feeling that his daughter
had been done wrong and so he joined up
with the opposition kicked out by Sister
this one more time in this
second exile of five sisters.
We.
He goes to various places to raise
all kinds of money gets mercenaries.
He is supported by and this will
play a role in later events.
He gets very friendly with the cavalryman
the horsemen the nobility of a red
area a town in the northern part of the
island of Nubia just off the east coast
of Attica.
And by the way of course remember
persisted as comes from that area the east
coast of Attica and regionalism will not
disappear from Attica for some time and
that is significant.
Anyway he gets all kinds of help from
overseas and his wealth and all that.
And this time he's just going to fight
his way back no tricks no goddesses.
He lands at Marathon which
has the advantage to him
of being very close to UBS
where he's been operating with
his friends in the rhetoric.
It also has a nice flat place for cavalry
and I'm sure he acquired cavalryman
among the mercenaries that he hired.
All of that allows him to get his forces
together and sure enough when he lands
at marathon that's his home territory
and all his people come rallying round to
him and now he has a good sized army of
Athenians and mercenaries and he marches
inland and in the middle land of
Attica at a place called Bellini.
He meets his opponents and defeats them
in battle and makes himself the tyrant
of Athens once again.
And
one of the things he does by a trick.
Very soon after coming to power is to
disarm the Athenian people so that he is
now ruling in a truly tyrannical way.
In that sense there's not
much of a pretense at having
achieved this position by
the popular will.
He's done so by force and trickery and
he's prepared to maintain his his power
in those ways but in his actual government
of Attica and Athens in the remainder
of his life tradition is pretty
clear that he did not rule harshly.
If you think of the word tyrannical
as meaning harsh he did not rule too
radically.
In fact later writers described the
way he ruled Athens and it's this last
period that they're talking about I think
as one that was politic costs meaning
moderately and in accordance with
the way a polis should be run.
Which does not include tyranny.
And in fact some later writers picture
of the rule of pipe sister cities as a
golden age in Athens.
We'll come back to that
perhaps but there you have it.
There are two edges to this thing there's
the notion my God establish a charity
which later on in Athens would be the
worst thing in the world you could do.
And yet there's this alongside it this
tradition of a decent government under my
system.
Well let's see what he did.
One thing he did was not to repeal the
laws of so long they may never have been
put into full effect because of the
turmoil but no one had ever said that not
the law anymore.
In fact by system this let them be and
in fact he allowed them to function as
they should in other words I would think
that there was a council of 400 that
was elected every year and met there.
We know there were magistrates.
There are cons elected in the
appropriate way each year.
Translate the law courts even met in the
way that they were supposed to but what
persisted as did was not to change
the Constitution but to dominate it.
I think you have to imagine that
there is the rule of a boss.
He doesn't change the laws.
He just sees to it that all
the appropriate bodies are
controlled by his people.
That for an analogy is the
way the mandatory governed
in Florence when they made
themselves the rulers of that republic.
It is true.
You can't be just totally gentle.
You have to take care of your enemies
because they're going to be enemies out
there.
So my sister is surely exiled
some aristocratic families
the ones who wouldn't
cut a deal with him.
The ones who wouldn't play ball out they
went and we know that for some part of
the time we don't know just when he exiled
the alchemy and it's of course he had
this quarrel with mega clique so that
was not a surprise and they could not
readily be made complacent.
What was going on.
Although we do have this is remarkable
we have an actual inscription which is
blatantly a list of our cousins who
were held office in Athens and after my
sister this is death in the period when
his sons ruled Athens one of the names
as Arkan of the city was Kleist Denise
who was in alchemy it which means makes
it perfectly clear that at least later
in the day the out minutes came back into
Attica.
We have to imagine that by system this
rule this thing with great savvy and
there was always time to come home if
you will be a good boy and do what my
sister told you to do.
And I think that happens in many cases.
One of the things he did it was very
popular was to invent the institution of
circuit judges.
That is to say it used to be that if
you were an Athenian citizen then you
wanted to go to law.
Originally of course you had no choice
but to go to the local big shot and have
this local aristocrats settle the matter
as had been the case in the days of he
said.
But under Solon's system at the very
least you could go to the magistrate in
Athens if you wanted to and you could
even appeal to his decision if you wanted
to.
But here's the problem what if you lived
in Sunni and you lived miles and miles
and miles away from this.
What are the chances that you would in
fact or could go to the city to receive
the justice that you needed.
So by establishing circuit justice brought
courts that were objective that were
not dominated by the local barons.
He was doing a real service
to the ordinary Athenian
citizen and that was seen
to be a good thing.
But it was also of course in his interest.
He doesn't want local big
shots being big shots.
There's only room in the tyranny for
one big shot. And that is the tyrant.
And so he's doing his.
He's serving himself breaking down local
power unifying the state into a single
thing which is good in all kinds of
ways but it's also good for the tyrant.
Now the next thing I'm
going to say is supposition.
We don't have any ancient evidence for
it and its course is open to doubt.
But I would argue that he must have
confiscated some of the land of the
aristocrats who opposed him and
with whom he did not make a deal.
And I say that pretty
much only for this reason
before my sister this we have the great
story of great differences in land
holding between very very big landowners
and very very small lands and those who
own no land at all producing the problem
nothing so long did directly affected
that situation.
But when we get into the fifth century
the evidence is overwhelming that we have
what I see.
But I spoke of earlier lots and lots of
medium moderate family sized farms some
big farms but these are not what
are characteristic of the place.
Well how did that happen.
When did that happen.
My guess is probably past
history has brought that about.
And if so it would have been still
another reason why he had broad popularity
remarkable popularity.
The ancient sources do tell us that
among the things that he did was to spend
money on farmers.
That is he would give money or lend
money to farmers who needed it when they
needed it which is of course one of
the issues constantly before the small
farmers of Attica so they could with the
money they borrowed they could buy more
land make their farm more self-sustaining
they could pay off debts that they owe
to other people they could do the things
that these small farmers have to do to
succeed namely buy the
equipment they need.
Olive presses wine presses mills they
should they could get use their loans for
planting fruit trees olive trees all of
these things could have been part of the
story of how a Athenian agriculture
came to be so so successful.
After the time of the tyrants
as they had not been before.
Now there's one negative thing that
I'm sure nobody liked prices for this
instituted the first regular direct tax
that we know of in Athenian history a 5
percent tax on all that was produced
from the land and that that money went to
pay sister this made him wealthy but also
provided him with the money he needed
to beat his good fellow
that I have been describing.
So it all assisted his political
power and his popularity.
But even there that should have
been the worst thing he ever did.
Tyrants laid down taxes.
Taxes are evidence of
tyranny and all that.
That's a totally the picture we get.
Aristotle tells this story.
One day my sister this
was traveling around the
countryside of Attica as a guest
he sometimes did and he went up on the
slopes of Mount high meadows not too far
from the city of Athens.
You go up there today the
notion of anybody farming
on that mountain is totally
incredible.
Nothing you could possibly grow on
Mountain Meadows but it's been deforested.
By that time.
So anyway it was an still lousy I mean
mountains are not great places for farms.
You may have noticed.
So anyway it goes up to this farmer and
he says say farmer what do you grow on
your farm.
The farmer you might have to imagine a
gnarled old mean nasty old guy saying on
my farm I grow rocks
and my sister this is
welcome to his 5 percent.
Well that did my sister to stay off with
his head or send him on to the moon.
He said Well aren't you
a cute little fellow.
I hereby declare your farm
exempt from taxes forever.
And it became a famous
thing that tax free farm.
It shows up in a business
teen encyclopedia.
That story that is still being told.
So that's you've got a very
special kind of tie right here.
We'll turn to the rest of his reign
and that of his sons. Next time.